digital foundry is sponsored by backface
the leader in crash and error reporting
for game developers click on the link in
the video description and sign up for
your freed file today
the rumors well the rumors actually
turned out to be true geforce rtx 3060
ti is a real thing a real graphics card
and we've been testing it over the last
week
now nvidia promises rtx 2080 super level
performance in a smaller cheaper and
more efficient ampere design and
spoilers that's exactly what our testing
shows they've delivered in fact if we're
looking at this new
mainstreamish contender as an upgrade
from a gtx 1070 or 1080 it's actually
really impressive and in actual fact
it's significantly faster than a gtx
1080 ti which is still a pretty good gpu
to this day in fact by my reckoning it
should outperform a titan xp all for 399
or 365 of our once great british pounds
that's assuming stock levels persist for
long enough for you to buy one of course
in terms of the specifications and
underlying architecture rtx 3060 ti uses
the same ga104 gpu as the rtx 3070 but
with fewer cuda cores
4864 versus 5800
on the higher end model the card also
operates at slightly lower clock speeds
to fit into a 20 watt lower tdp the
memory subsystems are unchanged however
with both cards getting the same 8 gigs
of gddr6 with 448 gigabytes per second
of bandwidth now it's good to see eight
gigs becoming the new standard all of
the next gen cards we've seen so far
have had at least that amount as well as
improvements to compute performance all
of the usual features of nvidia's ampere
architecture are present and correct
meaning that we're getting next
generation rate facing and tensor cores
so we can expect more noticeable
performance uplifts in raid facing and
ai accelerated workloads of course we've
covered ampere in more detail in our
earlier rtx reviews so let's move on to
the card's physical design now as usual
we're testing the founders edition
version of the card here which comes
with the same excellent industrial
design and well the same basic chassis
as the rtx 3070 same chip same chassis
same cooler and so in this case we're
getting two axial fans in a flow through
configuration with the small pennant
shaped motherboard design and the
miniature 12 pin power socket allowing
the final third of the cards to be
wholly used for cooling even the i o is
arranged to maximize airflow with a
single row of display outputs those
being three displayport 1.4 a's and one
hdmi 2.1 and they sit beneath a 16 by 5
grid of ventilation cutouts as with
other rtx 30 series cards 3060 ti is a
pci express 4.0 device but works in pcie
3.0 motherboards with no real loss of
performance now one of the biggest
questions we had in testing 3060 ti
beyond its gaming performance which
we'll get to soon well that's power
efficiency rtx 3070 was substantially
more efficient than its more powerful
siblings so how does the 3060 ti match
up to answer this question we use
nvidia's power capture analysis tool or
pcat an interposer board that sits
between pcie slot and the graphics card
as well as between
the 8 pin power input used by
ti and the power supply this way we can
measure the number of watts drawn by the
card itself completely isolating it from
the load of the rest of the system and
we can plot this power draw versus frame
rate to give us an idea of overall power
efficiency i'll let the table do the
talking here but basically in gears 5 30
60 ti hits a new efficiency record
whereas uh curiously in death stranding
is just a touch lower in efficiency
terms than the rtx 3070. obviously the
specter of big navi looms large here and
this too has its own efficiency
advantages i think overall both amd and
nvidia have done an excellent job here
in improving performance per watt from
their new architectures so let's dip
into game performance and i really want
to talk about 3060 ti as a replacement
for a legacy card um so you see the
headlines uh the pr from nvidia has been
about better than
2080 super performance which is 400 and
yeah i get that but fundamentally who's
actually going to be buying this thing i
see this product as a replacement for
something like a gtx 1070 which released
in 2016 for much the same price i do
feel it's important to place 3060 ti
within the ampere stack though and by
and large there is a frames per dollar
improvement over rtx 3070. now results
vary on a per game basis sometimes
dramatically but think of the 3070 as a
card that's typically around 10 to 15
percent faster but costs 25 more
in terms of which to buy well the advice
there is always the same get the most
expensive one you can afford with the
features that you want my benchmarks
will focus on 1440p resolution and we'll
be looking at it primarily in terms of
validating the 2080 super performance
claim but also seeing how this new
contender stacks up against gtx 1070 a
broadly priced equivalent card from 2016
and also 1080 ti the flagship from the
same pascal generation for comparisons
against many other cards at 1080p 1440p
and 2160p 4k yup as always we have all
of those numbers in our eurogamer review
and the link should be in the video
description below
okay so as you've been seeing from this
borderlands 3 benchmark nvidia's 2080
super performance claim is validated we
see it averaging across the whole
sequence
with just an eight percent lead but you
know that's still pretty good for the
record 30 70 the more expensive card is
13 points ahead still it's established
mainstream cards we're invested in here
where there's an almost doubling of
performance all told versus gtx 1070
while we're also looking at a 24
performance lead over 1080 ti
all of these leads actually increase by
a few points if we bench at 4k instead
but i feel that 1440p is the natural
resolution for this card so 3060 ti
slots into place at the bottom of the
new ampere stack but not by a massive
degree and meanwhile it's delivering a
big cost saving compared to turing with
big performance wins huge even against
pascal happy days
remedies control x which loves ampere
and doesn't much love
well anything other than modern gpu
architectures from nvidia if we're being
completely honest 1440p here is good for
a sustained 60 frames per second and
that's before we factor in the image
quality and performance enhancements for
dlss
anyway it's here where the old cards are
well and fully schooled there's a 2.3
times multiplier in performance against
gtx 1070 and a useful 53 improvement in
frame rate against 1080 ti
as you've seen though we're on level
pegging on average against 2080 super
all told we measured a 1.1 percent lead
so basically margin of error now control
thrives on ampere and the more ampere
you give it the happier it is to the
point where 30 70 is actually 17 faster
shadow the tomb raider next where once
again there's a slim lead overall up
against 2080 super just a couple of
percentage points really borderline
margin of error but still living up to
the marketing the 3060 ti is actually a
touch faster on the first two segments
while the final third sees 2080 super
and the new contender delivering point
for point identical scores but those
wide spaces on the graphing give you
some idea of the most likely upgrade
path here rtx 3060 ti is basically twice
as fast as gtx 1070 while 1080 ti only
hands in 72.5
overall of 3060 ti's performance
so the games tested so far thrive on
ampere that the titles that ran best on
3080 and 3070 and so it is with do
maternal tested on alt for nightmare
settings eight gigs of vram isn't quite
enough for top end texture caching at 4k
but it's just fine for 1440p and here
360ti offers up 88
of 3070s performance level and delivers
a 2.3 times multiplier to frame rates
versus 1070. so yeah as expected that's
pretty immense to the point where gtx
1080 ti can only deliver 68
of the 3060 ti's throughput this is all
pretty impressive stuff right part of
the reason it's so impressive is that
right now there is no amd rival
3060 ti is 27 ahead 5700 xt but yeah
those four games i've just covered there
they're titles that love the ampere
architecture but what happens when we
widen the scope and see how the new card
fares in other games and we'll start
with desk trending and a bit of an issue
in that benchmarking this title saw my
machine routinely crash when using
pascal cards did manage to get some 1070
and 1080 metrics though no 1080 ti
unfortunately so well this lineup will
have to do
okay so gen on gen death stranding
wasn't actually that great when looking
at 3080 versus 2080 but the 3060 ti does
just fine still four to five percentage
points ahead of 2080 super but again the
gains versus pascal are big
1070 only has an average 55 percent of
the 3060 ti's output and that rises to
68 against gtx 1080. the advantage for
3060 ti at 4k is actually even wider and
all of that is before we factor in dlss
which is a game changer in terms of
performance and isn't available on
pascal cards far cry 5 next and while
2080 super and 3060 ti at fade blows
the overall average sees both cards
delivering much the same performance
across the length of the test sequence
thus far we've seen gtx 1080 ti roundly
vanquished and 1070 basically monstered
and well yeah here 1070 can only hand in
56 percent of the 3060 ti's output
though
gets rather close to 89 percent the
closest we've seen the old pascal
champion get to matching the new ampere
offering
interestingly at 1440p
3070 is only 9
faster and i suspect that may well be
down to some kind of cpu limitation far
cry 5 here is heavily dependent on
single core cpu power and the limits can
be found even with an overclocked 10 900
k
the gap actually closes still further in
assassin's creed odyssey where 1080 ti
is only 10 points off the pace actually
dropping to just seven percent off the
pace at 4k the venerable 1070 can only
deliver 61 percent of the 360 ti's
output though but interestingly at 4k
ultra hd
3060 ti is basically twice as fast a
quick look at dirt rally 2.0 here a game
i'm including because well interestingly
enough it's the only example in our test
suite where we saw 2080 super outperform
3060 ti i mean it's 2.6 percent faster
overall across an extremely long
benchmark so hardly likely to be
noticeable during the run of play but an
interesting if somewhat academic data
point
you're still getting big big gains over
pascal 1070 only has 53 percent of 360
ti's performance level that rises to 86
for 1080 ti
a very quick look at rate facing next no
real point including 1070 or 1080 ti in
these metrics as well dxr titles will
run with ray tracing enabled there's no
hardware acceleration so performance is
going to be awful
so instead we're swapping in more
expensive cards that do have rt support
rtx 3070 and rx 6800 from amd
metfo exodus if you haven't noticed is
our first port of call where we find a
14 lead for the 30 70 but the 30 60 ti
is still pretty impressive beating 2080
super by almost 7
and yeah 360 ti also manages to sneak a
four percent lead over rx 6800 a card
that costs 180 dollars more this is a
really interesting use of hardware
accelerated rt by the way focusing
entirely on global illumination and
emissives battlefield 5 is an
interesting one where one of the first
dxr enabled games focuses exclusively on
raid faced reflections frame rate
average in this sequence is around 70
frames per second on 360ti but there's
an almost eight percent performance lead
over 2080 super secure state of affairs
because we only clock the 30 70 is
running around 10 percent faster in this
sequence
meanwhile it's another win against amd
with the 6800 offering up 87
of 3060 ti's performance level and we're
gonna end for now with remedies control
which runs the gamut of raidface
features all of them enabled here from
shadows to reflections and much much
more
3060 ti offers up almost 12 of extra
performance over 2080 super while rx
6800 only delivers 84
of the new tis output and yeah 30 70
here you get an extra 12 and a half
percent of extra frame rate over 30 60
ti fascinating stuff overall as here in
the raid-faced arena 3060 ti is more
handily outperforming 2080 super and of
course we're not benching with dlss
active here which boosts image quality
and improves frame rates and makes that
golf versus amd even wider
so i think that basically tells you
everything you need to know really rtx
3060 ti is a really nicely priced
product it brings strong 1440p
performance out of the box and with dlss
it should work really well at 4k too
i've mentioned it a couple of times but
i've showcased 1440p benchmarks here but
the differentials at 4k are actually a
touch wider still i've got no doubts at
all that this card is going to be a big
success because fundamentally the price
point steers it more towards those on
older generation mid-range cars this may
well be their first gpu with next-gen
features and yeah up against pascal it's
an enormous improvement in performance
for much the same money if msrps hold up
of course i've not included 5700 xt in
the comparisons too much because it
really is way off the pace but i would
expect to see a medium navi appearing in
the not too distant future which if
scaled down from big navi should be very
competitive in everything except raid
facing and machine learning functions
but yeah let's not go down that rabbit
hole just yet let's wait and see what
the actual product looks like in the
here and now at least 3060 ti is a class
apart in its performance level and slots
in nicely in the existing ampere lineup
so that's everything i've got for you
now please do like subscribe and share
if you enjoyed the content and ring the
bell for instant notifications whenever
digital foundry posts new youtube videos
live streams or whatever and for those
that want to support the team more
directly and get everything we do in
pristine quality well that's what our
patreon is for and i recommend checking
it out obviously but that's all from me
for now and as always i'd just like to
say thanks for watching and supporting
digital foundry don't lose players to
game errors and crashes instability will
happen throughout the game development
cycle during play testing beta cycles or
after you've released backed face was
developed to automate the capture and
analysis of crashes hangs and non-fatal
errors across playstation xbox nintendo
pc mac stadia and more our unique data
platform allows you to index anything
integrate with gyro slack discord and
run analytic workloads to better
prioritize and understand your game
stability many of the industries aaa
studios depend on backface you should
too click on the link in the video
description and sign up for your free
trial today